bonjour bonjour à tous merci de nous
rejoindre en direct de la salle des
conférences du sénat pour suivre la
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
une séance dominée aujourd'hui par des
interpellations sur les transports
aériens deux questions une du sénateur
ump roger karoutchi et puis une autre de
la sénatrice communiste annie david
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales ici au sénat également deux
questions cet après-midi sur les
collectivités territoriales notamment le
problème de financement des
collectivités territoriales c'est
notamment la ministre du budget valérie
pécresse qui répondra à la première
question
et puis sinon les thématiques abordées
cet après midi tourne autour des
scandales sanitaires notamment les
problèmes les prothèses mammaires la
précarité énergétique ou encore la
situation financière de la grèce vous le
voyez sur ces images le président du
sénat jean-pierre bel se dirige vers
l'hémicycle du sénat il va présider
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement qui va donc démarrer
d'ici une minute ou deux une grande
partie des membres du gouvernement et
bien sûr présents dans l'hémicycle
c'est d'après midi pour répondre aux
interpellations aux interpellations des
sénateurs parmi les autres thèmes
abordés également aujourd'hui est bien
une question du sénateur ump de paris
philippe dominati sur l'immobilier à
paris louis pinton le sénateur ump lui
interpellera le gouvernement sur la sncf
et puis enfin le sénat le sénateur non
inscrit philippe darniche posera une
question sur le plan alzheimer
voilà je vous propose tout de suite de
rejoindre donc l'hémicycle pour suivre
en direct cette séance on se retrouve
bien sûr ici après avec nos invités des
ministres des sénateurs pour débattre de
toutes ces questions d'actualité à tout
à l'heure
disposant chacun de deux minutes trente
la parole est à monsieur gilbert barbier
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social européen
ce président mais ce premier ministre
ministre me donne ma question s'adresse
à monsieur lui celui travail de l'emploi
de la santé médiator prothèse pip et
médicaments périmés de gêne au faron
implants auditifs d'honneur elec
substituer l'acide hyaluronique chaque
semaine révèle un nouveau scandale de
malversations de tromperie voir
d'escroquerie dans le domaine de la
santé et ce sont des laboratoires
français qui sont en cause dans un
secteur industriel considéré comme
florissant bien sûr l'objet ces affaires
font l'objet d'enquêtés judiciaires qui
démontreront les exactes responsabilité
cependant elle rélève sinon une
défaillance à tout le moins à une grave
insuffisance dans les organismes publics
de contrôle plusieurs missions
parlementaires et notamment celles que
j'ai présidé en 2006 l'ont déjà souligné
que ce soit dans le processus de mise
sur le marché
sur le rôle du cep est ce pour les
matériels de soins où le diagnostic que
ce soit système de surveillance en cours
d'usagé sur la suite des fabrications et
l'origine des matières premières avec la
multiplicité des intervenants
on ne sait qui fait quoi qui prend les
décisions
lesquels sont souvent prise tardivement
d'ailleurs par rapport à d'autres pays
sans rappeler la sphère du médiateur
comment comprendre que les prothèses
frauduleuse pp a été retiré du marché
seulement en 2010 alors que dès 1996 les
pratiques de cette société ont
interpellé les autorités
tout ceci provoque les suspicions sur
les responsables
l'inquiétude justifiée nos concitoyens
geste jette l'opprobre sur le produit en
france
j'ai personnellement toujours considéré
que cette dilution des responsabilités
est appelée judiciable à la sécurité
sanitaire
et j'avais proposé en son temps de
regrouper tous en une seule agence
je sais que ce n'est pas le sentiment du
minist soit mais peut-on me faire le
point sur les réformes prévues pour
redresser un système défaillant et
restaurer la crédibilité des autorités
sanitaires à tous les niveaux si nous
les prenons garde la main il peut y
avoir d'autres scandales notamment sur
les produits diététiques en vente libre
par exemple sent une âme même il nous
faut à l'évidence plus de déontologie de
rigueur dans les procédures pour que nos
concitoyens retrouve conscience
confiance en notre système de santé
merci pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame nora berra se termine pas à 900
points merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur barbier vous
remercie de me donner l'opportunité de
faire le point sur les mesures que nous
avons prises face aux drames sanitaires
récents c'est vrai que le scandale du
médiator a révélé la nécessité de
réformer notre système de sécurité
sanitaire avec un seul objectif ultime
c'est effectivement renforcée restaurer
la confiance dans cet objectif la
méthode vous la connaissez des missions
parlementaires des assises du médicament
la mission d'inspection qui avait été
confiée à l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales et tous ces travaux
ont conduit à des propositions concrètes
qui ont fait le socle en tout cas de la
loi du 29 décembre 2011
rien ne sera plus comme avant il y a un
avant et un après médiator puisque cette
loi a permis d'avancer sur trois piliers
majeurs la lutte contre les conflits
d'intérêt avec une transparence dans les
décisions
le doute qui bénéficie systématiquement
au patient et enfin des professionnels
de santé bien formés et des patients
surtout bien informée les changements
sont profonds
ils sont profonds parce qu'ils
permettent aujourd'hui de concilier la
sécurité des patients et l'accès à
l'innovation thérapeutique
s'agissant des pays paie je serais quand
même dire un mot c'est vrai que il faut
dire le dossier date d'avant la loi du
29 décembre
2011 et je crois que ces strates
important a noté l'anc est que nous
avons commandé avec xavier bertrand qui
a été menée par la direction générale de
la santé et l'agencé du médicament a mis
en évidence une tromperie de grande
ampleur du fabricant c'est pourquoi nous
avons pris avec guy bertrand des mesures
pour encadrer les dispositifs médicaux
d'abord au niveau national en
généralisant les inspections contrôle en
les rendant plus plus inopinés plus
systématique et puis en facilitant en
rendant plus facile et plus accessible
rapide
la remontée des effets indésirables en
tout cas des des effets effectivement de
l'attendu au niveau européen il faut là
aussi agir pour cela nous nous sommes
concertés avec nos collègues ministres
européens et nous avons six saisi la
commission européenne pour accélérer la
révision de la directive sur les
dispositifs médicaux vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur la mobilisation du
gouvernement est entière pour prendre
toutes les mesures visant à préserver la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans notre
système de sécurité des produits de
santé
merci la parole est à monsieur roger
karoutchi pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
c'est le président monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse à
monsieur mariani ministre des transports
elle est en fait à double facette mais
c'est évidemment le même problème
le droit de grève monsieur le ministre
est un droit constitutionnel qu
absolument personne ne remet en cause
mais mais la liberté de circulation
la liberté d'information le souci commun
j'en suis sûr dans tous les pans de cet
hémicycle des voyageurs de ceux qui se
déplacent des familles de ceux qui
travaillent de ceux qui vont vers les
aéroports
c'est un souci important qu'est ce que
nous constatons nous constatons que au
niveau aérien
au delà du droit de grève il y à ce que
l'on appelle gentiment ce moment les
annulations à froid et puis il ya les
annulations à chaud la différence
subtile c'est que les annulations à
froid c'est quand les gens ont organisé
que l'on sait quels sont les vols
annulés et les annulations à chaud c'est
le matin vous arrivé à l'aéroport avec
votre famille ou pour aller travailler
et on vous annonce hier soir on vous a
dit que le vol était maintenu ce matin
l'équipage a pas voulu donc vous rester
là est ce que cette situation peut durer
monsieur le ministre
naturellement non il ne s'agit pas il ne
s'agit pas d'encadrer ou de limiter le
droit de grève
il s'agit seulement d'organiser
d'organiser et de faire en sorte que
ceux qui ont légitimement le droit de
grève disent qu'ils font grève de
manière à ce que le service aérien soit
organisé il est inacceptable sincèrement
que ce soit pour des déplacements privés
des familles ou pour les déplacements
professionnels de ceux qui travaillent
d'apprendre en arrivant à l'aéroport que
l'avion est annulé c'est un système qui
n'est pas acceptable et nous aurons la
semaine prochaine un débat ici même sur
la proposition de loi des regards je
précise d'ailleurs qu'il ne s'agit pas
contrairement à la ratp et à la sncf
d'un service minimum mais bien de
l'organisation d'un service
je vous demande monsieur le ministre
puisque vous recevez demain les
syndicats de nous dire qu'est ce que
vous prévoyez de leur dire est-ce que
naturellement nous maintenons nous
soutenons ce texte qui tend
organisé en ayant une déclaration 48
heures deuxième élément une masse 15
secondes
air france dit on perd 10 millions
d'euros par jour
air france a mis en place un plan de
rééquilibrage financier de d'un milliard
d'euros monsieur le ministre
au delà des 10 millions d'euros par jour
d air france compagnie qui va finir par
être menacée dans son existence
est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi des
conséquences économiques pour l'ensemble
du pays et ses conséquences sont elles
estimées aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre merci de vos réponses
merci monsieur thierry mariani ministre
chargé des transports monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur roger
karoutchi
la réponse est simple est-ce que le
gouvernement entend soutenir et
continuer à soutenir cette proposition
de loi la réponse est oui
la grève qui agite les transports
aériens depuis quatre jours vous le
savez a pour origine la proposition de
loi un derrick byars qui a été examiné à
l'assemblée nationale le 24 janvier
dernier et que vous examinerez dans cet
hémicycle le 15 février prochain
le résultat concret de cette grève
monsieur karoutchi avec des pilotes qui
ne prennent pas leurs services d
annulation comme vous l'avez décrit à
chaud des passagers hébergés le soir
dans des hôtels et bien le résultat est
justement de conforter le gouvernement
dans cette dans sa détermination à
soutenir cette loi qui plus que jamais
apparaît nécessaire
je le répète cette proposition de loi
vise à permettre une meilleure
organisation des transports aériens en
cas de grève de l'une ou l'autre des
catégories de salariés impliqués dans la
réalisation d'un vol en imposant un
préavis individuel de 48 heures elle
répond à cet objectif puisque ce délai
permettra effectivement au gestionnaire
aéroportuaire et aux compagnies
aériennes de s'organiser c'est tout
la notion de service garanti elle
apporte aussi davantage de garanties au
plan social en imposant la négociation
préalable d'accords cadres à l'instar de
ce qui se fait avec succès dans le
secteur ferroviaire
depuis 2007 les députés le savent pour
l'avoir débattue il ya quinze jours et
vous pourrez en juger vous même la
semaine prochaine
cette loi jeu
dis je le répète ne concerne pas le
droit de grève
elle touche simplement à l'organisation
des transports en cas de conflit quant à
air france la situation est la suivante
les pilotes sont quasiment les seuls à
faire grève et air france est quasiment
la seule compagnie aujourd'hui touchées
elle a fortement réduit ses programmes
de vols durant ces quatre jours
et aujourd'hui cette transformation de
l'entreprise en réduisant aussi les
impacts des différents conflits sociaux
sur cette situation financière merci
merci
la parole est un monsieur vincent
capo-canellas pour le groupe de l'union
centriste et républicaine
monsieur le président monsieur
prémunissent mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
ma question s'adresse à madame le
ministre du budget des comptes publics
et la réforme de l'état
madame le ministre le gouvernement a
confirmé hier que l'exécution du budget
pour l'année 2011
établissez un déficit de 90 8 milliards
d'euros contre 148 lui 8 milliards pour
l'année 2010
cette bonne nouvelle sur le front des
déficits et de la lutte contre la dérive
des finances publiques mérite d'être
salué pour autant nous mesurerons tout
le chemin qui reste à accomplir
si ce bon résultat permet de situer le
déficit à la hauteur de 5,4 pour cent du
produit intérieur brut contre 5 7%
attendus nous savons combien les efforts
qui restent à accomplir doivent être au
coeur de la stratégie de l'état dans les
prochaines années
la cour des comptes a publié hier son
rapport annuel lequel rappelle
l'importance de la lutte contre les
déficits
ces recommandations sont basées sur la
précédente estimation du déficit
on sait que depuis ce chiffre a été revu
à la baisse pour autant la cour souligne
l'objectif à atteindre
revenir au niveau de la moyenne de la
zone euro estimée à 3 7% du pib puis
parvenir à un étiage de déficit se situe
en a deux et demi pour cent afin de
réduire notre endettement
la cour des comptes souligne certes
l'ambition du gouvernement qui veut
réduire fortement le déficit en 2012
mais elle invite à de nouvelles mesures
de redressement compte tenu du
ralentissement économique prévu madame
le ministre
un budget 2012 et le collectif
budgétaire adopté hier en conseil des
ministres permettent ils de répondre à
cet objectif et pour l'avenir comment
répartir équitablement l'effort entre
les différentes administrations les
comptes sociaux et les collectivités
locales
monsieur le président la république
réunit demain les associations d'élus
locaux pour évoquer l'effort financier
attendu de la part des collectivités
locales une telle perspective suppose un
moratoire sur l'avalanche de normes
divers
fort coûteuses que les collectivités
subissent la préoccupation première des
collectivités aujourd'hui et la
recherche de financements pour leurs
programmes d'investissement
l'assèchement du marché des prêts aux
collectivités locales appellent
également des mesures immédiates et une
décision quant à la création d'un nouvel
établissement issu de la banque postale
et de la caisse des dépôts
madame le ministre pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur les mesures envisagées pour
assurer la poursuite de la lutte contre
les déficits
au regard des résultats obtenus en 2011
comme des recommandations de la cour des
comptes
pouvez-vous enfin confirmé devant le
sénat la volonté du gouvernement de
répondre à un objectif de justice dans
la répartition ses efforts en
particulier en direction des
collectivités locales merci madame
valérie pécresse ministre du budget des
comptes publics de la réforme de l'état
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vincent capo-canellas ce vous
soulignez à juste titre la bonne gestion
qui a été celle du gouvernement en 2011
puisque nous venons d'avoir les
résultats de l'exécution budgétaire pour
l'année 2011 et je crois que
pratiquement jamais depuis 1945
nous n'avons fait d'une année sur
l'autre un effort aussi conséquents en
matière de réduction des déficits vous
l'avez dit 48 milliards d'euros de
baisse des déficits publics en un an
c'est spectaculaire et c'est beaucoup
mieux que prévu puisque nous étions
engagés à baisser le déficit à 5,7 pour
cent de la richesse nationale
il sera à 5 4 peut-être même encore en
dessous nous attendons les chiffres
définitifs des collectivités locales et
les administrations de sécurité sociale
alors ces bons résultats sont dus à quoi
monsieur sénateurs ils sont dus à notre
constance à réduire les dépenses
publiques à notre bonne gestion et en
même temps aux efforts de redressement
qui ont été demandés par le premier
ministre aux français en cours d'année
alors ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui
aux français c'est que leurs efforts
portent leurs fruits puisque nous sommes
en mesure de tenir nos engagements de
déficit pour 2011 et que nous prenons de
l'est
laon pour 2012 parce qu'évidemment avec
3 milliards 6 de bonnes nouvelles qui
sont reportables sur 2012
nous n'avons jamais été aussi crédible
pour tenir nos engagements 2012 et je
sais que la cour des comptes était
inquiète
hier mais elle se fondait sur des
prévisions de croissance 2012 de 1 % qui
viennent d'être révisée par le
gouvernement à 0,5
elle se fondait sur un déficit 2011 à 5
7% qui a été révisé hier à en dessous de
5 4%
donc les nouvelles vous le voyez sont
bonnes nous avons des marges de
manoeuvre et de sécurité dans le budget
6 milliards d'euros de réserves de
précaution qui seront mobilisés dans le
cadre du collectif pour sécuriser notre
trajectoire et nos engagements
alors oui ce gouvernement tient ses
engagements mais il faudra aller
beaucoup plus loin et la cour des
comptes nous l'a rappelé hier il faudra
retourner à l'équilibré budgétaire
l' équilibre budgétaire ces 115
milliards d'euros d' efforts qui seront
demandés à la nation il faut et c'est
l'engagement du gouvernement
deux tiers de réductions de dépenses un
tiers de nouvelles recettes c'est notre
engagement
j'espère que ce sera celui de tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
merci la parole et à monsieur michel
berson pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre je voudrais
interpeller le ministre chargé de
l'énergie
la france connaît une vague de grand
froid qui met en lumière la situation
noire de la pauvreté nous avons tous
conscience du drame que vivent les
personnes sans domicile fixe comme en
témoigne le décès de cette femme morte
de froid
le week-end dernier mais ses taux que 3
millions 800 mille ménages sont
aujourd'hui victimes de précarité
énergétique que 620 mille familles les
plus démunies éprouve doublement des
difficultés pour se chauffer et pour
payer leurs factures d'énergie parce
qu'elle cumule contraintes financières
et habitation mal isolées elles doivent
dès lors choisir ou se chauffer au
risque d'impayés ou avoir froid au
détriment de leur santé en france en
dans notre république c'est
insupportable d'autant plus
insupportable que les français les plus
pauvres n'en peuvent plus d'attendre les
mesures du gouvernement qui leur
permettrait de bénéficier d'un véritable
bouclier social d'un véritable même
bouclier énergétique
le dispositif actuel du tarif de
première nécessité a fait la preuve de
son inefficacité et de son insuffisance
95 euros de réduction sur une facture
annuelle de chauffage électrique de 1600
euros
c'est dérisoire 650 mille bénéficiaires
pour 2 millions d'éligible c'est un
échec
le tarif de première nécessité n'est
accordé qu'aux prix de démarches
administratives digne du parcours du
combattant
le gouvernement avait promis que ce
tarif serait attribué de manière
automatique
le 1er janvier 2012 le décret n'est
toujours pas publié
il fallut attendre les grands froids
pour que soit annoncé que le décret
serait rétroactif
lors de sa publication la vérité c'est
que le gouvernement reste sourd aux
difficultés des ménages qui n'arrivent
plus à payer leurs factures de gaz et
d'électricité pourtant l'énergie est un
bien vital qui doit être accessible à
tous
la précarité est une injustice qu'il
faut combattre
alors monsieur le ministre quand le
gouvernement instaurera t-il une
tarification du gaz et de l'électricité
progressive est différenciée selon les
usages qu'en lancera-t-il un vrai plan
national de renforcement de l'isolation
thermique des logements
quant aux mettra-t-il en place une
politique qui réponde à l'urgence
sociale de la précarité énergétique
merci monsieur pierre lellouche
secrétaire d'état chargé du commerce
extérieur
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bert sont alignés des contre
vérités ne fait pas une vérité
le gouvernement a fait de la lutte
contre la précarité énergétique je vais
le prouver
l'une des priorités de sa politique
énergétique tout d'abord nous assurons
une énergie la moins chère possible à
tous les français grâce à la
préservation de notre atout nucléaire
est d'ailleurs monsieur monsieur besson
était aujourd'hui même avec le président
de la république à fessenheim c'est une
énergie 40% moins chère qu'ailleurs en
europe sur le gaz
nous avons bloqué les tarifs en 2011
mais avons limité la hausse à 4,4 pour
cent au 1er janvier 2012 grâce notamment
aux renégociation de contrats que nous
avons demandé à gdf suez pour le fioul
et carburants
nous assurons une transparence absolue
des prix et des marges grâce à cette
action
le marché français est l'un des plus
concurrentiels en europe et les marges y
sont parmi les plus basses ensuite nous
traitons les situations d'urgence j'y
viens monsieur berson en aidant
financièrement les messages les ménages
les plus modestes pour l'électricité
nous avons un tarif social
rv à lire revalorisé de 10 points l'an
dernier la réduction moyenne est de 90
euros environ pour le gaz ce
gouvernement a mis en place un tarif
social en 2008
nous l'avons revalorisé de 20% en avril
2011 et nous venons de le revaloriser
encore au 1er janvier pour un foyer
lol chauffés au gaz le rabais annuel et
256 euros en électricité comme un gaz
nous avons par ailleurs automatisés
l'attribution des tarifs sociaux ou 1er
janvier pour que les ménages qui ne
pensent pas à le demander en bénéficient
quand même c'est à dire près des deux
tiers des 1,5 million de foyers
concernés aujourd'hui
par ailleurs les coupures d'électricité
et de gaz sont interdites pendant
l'hiver pour les ménages en difficulté
tout foyer qui éprouvent des difficultés
à régler ses fournisseurs d'énergie peut
saisir
le fonds de solidarité pour le logement
en vue d'une aide tant que le fonds n'a
pas statué l'électricité le gaz ne
peuvent pas être coupé de + électricité
et gaz sont obligatoirement maintenue du
1er novembre au 15 avril pour tous les
foyers ayant eu recours à l'aide du
fonds de solidarité dans les douze
années mois nous menons enfin une action
de long terme pour aider les ménages en
difficulté à réduire durablement leur
facture pour cela nous avons en
particulier créé un fonds d aide à la
rénovation thermique des logements
doté de 1,35 milliard d'euros dont 1,1
milliard financés par l'état ce fonds
bénéficie à plus de trois cent mille
foyers
voilà monsieur le sénateur l'ensemble de
ces actions qu'elle correspond pas du
tout aux accusations que vous avez
préféré
merci la parole est à présent monsieur
andré gattolin pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président madame et
messieurs les ministres ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre d'état
ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur alain juppé alors nous parlons
nous ignorons si un accord sera trouvé
ce soir sur les conditions posées à la
grèce par le fmi la bce et la commission
européenne en vue de l'obtention d'une
ligne de financement
à ce pays d'éviter un défaut de paiement
le 20 mars prochain
parmi les principales exigences de cette
fameuse troïka nous savons qu'après les
différents plans d'austérité déjà engagé
par la grèce ces derniers mois figurent
une baisse de 20% des salaires une
réduction de 15% des retraites
complémentaires et une suppression de
15000 emplois publics
le tout dans un pays en récession depuis
plus de cinq ans et dont le pib devrait
encore cette année connaître un recul
d'environ 6%
alors oui les gouvernements grecs
successifs ont de lourdes
responsabilités dans cette situation oui
la société grecque doit se réformer et
se moderniser ainsi l'église orthodoxe
première fortune de france ne fait
toujours pas d'impôts de même que la
plupart des grands armateurs grecs
la grèce est aujourd'hui le pays
d'europe où les inégalités sociales sont
les plus élevés et c'est précisément aux
populations défavorisées aux classes
moyennes que nous demandons aujourd'hui
de régler la facture
les capitaux privés du pays ont déjà fui
en masse vers l'angleterre et surtout
vers la suisse au cours des derniers
mois les banques suisses comptent ainsi
220 milliards d'euros détenus par des
grecs qu'ils ne paient pas ou presque
pas d'impôts dans leur pays et que nous
propose la france et son allié allemand
der cette façon et femi vieille école
celle là même qui dans les années 70 ont
précipité nombre de démocraties dans le
chaos c'est parfois même la dictature
monsieur le ministre il n'est nul besoin
d'être prix nobel d'économie pour savoir
que la récession sans fin dans laquelle
nous plongeons la grecque la grèce par
ces mesures ne lui permettra pas de voir
son économie redémarrer et que nous nous
dirigeons tout droit vers de nouveaux
plans de sauvetage lors des prochaines
échéances du remboursement de sa dette
l'union européenne ne pourrait-elle pas
à l'instar de ce que vient d'obtenir les
états unis forcer les banques suisses à
lever le secret bancaire pour que l'état
grec puisse enfin réclamé et recouvrir
son dû auprès d'une oligarchie national
très peu soucieuse de l'intérêt général
ce serait là un vrai signe de solidarité
à l'égard de la population grecque
comme il serait un signe de
considération et de courage politique
que le sommet de notre diplomatie face
enfin le voyage d'athènes et a expliqué
sur place
les raisons qui conduisent notre
gouvernement à soutenir des mesures qui
aux yeux de l'opinion grecque sont
perçus comme aussi injuste
qu'incompréhensible merci monsieur
pierre lellouche secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce extérieur
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
gâteau l'injure est d'abord excusé
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances qui ne peut pas être
présent aujourd'hui
concernant la situation grecque le
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy et la chancelière merkel ont
rappelé sans ambiguïté à plusieurs
reprises les scénarios qui sont en ce
moment même sur la table je leur dis
avec beaucoup de solennité les états
membres de la zone euro sont déterminés
à défendre la stabilité financière de la
zone
nous ferons preuve d'une très forte
solidarité avec tous les membres de la
zone euro
nous l'avons rappelé de plusieurs à
plusieurs reprises et nous y sommes
engagés solennellement pour autant cette
solidarité n'a de sens que si elle
s'accompagne d'un sursaut national en
grèce la grèce doit entreprendre des
réformes structurelles profondes pour
restaurer la compétitivité de son
économie et la soutenabilité de ses
finances publiques
elle s'est d'ailleurs engagé auprès de
l'ensemble de ses partenaires publics
comme privés elle doit maintenant
respecter ses engagements
je veux vous l'assuré monsieur le
sénateur une solution ambitieuse et
globale à la crise grecque est possible
tous les paramètres sont désormais
connus et les négociations avec le
secteur privé devrait déboucher sur un
accord tout prochainement les autorités
grecques le peuple grec dont nous
respectons naturellement la pleine et
entière souveraineté doivent décider
quelle voie il souhaite désormais
privilégiée pour l'avenir de leur pays
et ils devront s'y tenir
il ya d'un côté la voie que nous
préconisons que préconisent tous les
experts internationaux qui travaillent
en ce moment même sur le dossier grec
c'est la voie des réformes structurelles
profondes qui sont indispensables pour
que l'économie grecque sortent renforcés
de cette crise mais il ya également la
voie qui consisterait à rejeter la
solidarité européenne et à refuser les
réformes qui sont associés
et dans ce cas ce serait une voie plus
aventureuses mais si c'est la décision
du peuple grec
je vous le répète encore une fois nous
respecterons ce choix comme nous
respectons leur souveraineté
je comprends que les négociations au
sein du gouvernement grec progresse il
est impératif qu'elle soit achevée avant
leur groupe de ce soir et qu'un accord
global soit conclu avec le groupe
d'experts de la commission européenne du
fmi et de la banque centrale européenne
merci la parole et à madame la
présidente annie davy pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mariani ministre en
charge du transport
c'est par une proposition de loi déposée
par vos députés ump proposition de loi
qui vous permet d'ailleurs de contourner
l'obligation légale de consulter les
partenaires sociaux que votre majorité
et vous même attaqué le droit de grève
dans le secteur aérien privé
nul doute qu'après les salariés de
l'aérien vous vous attaquerez à
l'ensemble des salariés
c'est cette proposition satisfait
pleinement le medef elle bafoue notre
constitution mais aussi notre droit du
travail
car en effet par cette simple
proposition de loi d'affichage et à la
veille de l'élection présidentielle vous
remettez frontalement en cause le
principe constitutionnel du droit de
grève
n'en déplaise à monsieur sarkozy à
madame parisot
le droit de grève n'est pas un privilège
c'est au contraire l'un des piliers de
notre république et de notre démocratie
ce droit acquis de haute lutte par les
salariés a permis la construction de
notre modèle social dont vous osez vous
revendiquez avec cette mesure
vous continuez à opposer nos concitoyens
entre eux il n'y a pas d'un côté ce qui
devrait avoir un droit garanti de
voyager et d'un autre des salariés en
lutte pour défendre tout simplement
leurs droits si les salariés se
mobilisent c'est pour leurs conditions
de travail pour des rémunération décente
et pour le maintien de l'emploi
ils se mobilisent en réalité dans
l'intérêt de tous les salariés
contrairement à l'idée que vous
véhiculez
les salariés n'abuse pas du droit de
grève c'est leur seule défense face au
mépris des employeurs et soyez certains
que les salariés préfèrent toujours un
bon accord un mauvais conflit une grève
qui coûte cher aux salariés ce n'est pas
une plaie partie de plaisir seuls ceux
qui n'ont jamais fait grève peuvent
penser cela contrairement à ce que vous
laissez entendre ce ne sont pas les
salariés qui sont responsables des
difficultés économiques d'air france
elles ne sont que le résultat de vos
politiques continuent de
déréglementation laissant le secteur
aérien au profit des seuls actionnaires
la réalité c'est que les usagers des rer
des trains des métros ou de l'avion sont
victimes d'une politique de casse du
service public
et certainement pas du droit de grève
qui rappelons le mes chers collègues
pour le transport parisien ne concerne
que 2 % des difficultés de service
monsieur monsieur le ministre
cesser les provocations destinées à
satisfaire la frange la plus droitière
de votre électorat
allez-vous avant de rencontrer des
organisations syndicales retirer cette
proposition de loi de l'ordre du jour ce
retrait serait pour le moins un
préalable à de véritables négociations
avec les organisations syndicales sur
leurs conditions de travail et sur leur
salaire t monsieur thierry mariani
ministre chargé des transports
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame david vous m'interrogez
finalement sur la le même sujet évoqué
tout à l'heure le sénateur roger
karoutchi
mais pardonnez moi avec une approche un
peu différente où j'ai beaucoup de mal à
vous suivre
oh j'ai beaucoup de mal à vous suivre
tan tan franchement ça s'apparente plus
à une caricature qu'à une véritable
question est ce que la négociation
sociale
est ce qu'il y a consultation des
syndicats
votre collègue à l'assemblée nationale
qui a été le rapporteur auditionné 28
personnes je tiens à votre disposition
la liste de tous les syndicats cfdt cftc
cgt force ouvrière syndicat national des
pilotes de ligne vingt-huit personnes
ont été auditionnées
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
donc ne parlait pas d'absence de
concertation sociale d'autre part je
suis quand même surpris qu'une sénatrice
reproche à des parlementaires d'avoir eu
un projet d'initiative parlementaire
deuxièmement deuxièmement est ce que
vous croyez pas là aussi que je sais que
le 1er avril approche mais que vous êtes
un peu dans la caricature quand vous
dites reconnais la poussée un projet de
loi pour satisfaire le medef c'est un
projet loi surtout pour faire en sorte
que nos concitoyens ne soient plus pris
en otage c'est un projet de loi qui
permet
madame madame vous viendrez avec moi
expliquer ce soir si vous voulez si
encore des passagers bloqués que c'est
génial ce droit de grève et que s'ils
passent la nuit à orly s'il passe la
nuit à roissy
c'est vraiment une grande conquête
sociale en réalité c'est simplement ce
projet de loi fait pour garantir aux
passagers un minimum d'informations et
arrêter de caricaturer en disant que le
droit de grève est remis en cause grâce
à notre majorité depuis 2007 le service
minimum existe dans le transport
terrestre est ce que le droit de grève
et n'existe plus à la sncf
est ce que le droit de grève n'existe
plus à la ratp et bien ce que nous
allons faire c'est exactement la même
chose dans l'aérien
c'est à dire que le droit de grève bien
sûr reste garanti
simplement les toits cette période de 48
heures permettra aux passagers d'être
informé voilà et puis je crois qu'il
faut je crois qu'il faut arrêter un peu
cette vision manichéenne d'une économie
prolétarienne ou je ne sais quoi j'ai vu
que les trois candidats de l'ultra
gauche
j'ai vu que les trois candidats de
l'ultra gauche s'étaient déplacés pour
soutenir les pilotes c'était un grand
moment de solidarité prolétarienne
je dis simplement qu'il faut penser
aussi aux passagers qu'il faut madame
aussi penser aux passagers qui sont
aussi des travailleurs et qui ont aussi
des droits
merci la forme est un monsieur philippe
dominati pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur michel mercier
garde des sceaux alcoolique séropositifs
n'est pas de nationalité française
ancien sdf ce sont des annotations qu'à
constater la cnil dans le fichier du
principal offices hlm de france celui de
la ville de paris qui gère 125 mille
foyers sociaux les premières plaintes
ont commencé il ya un an une centaine de
familles au mois de février il ya un an
elles n'ont pas été entendues en
septembre de cette année une seconde
plainte at&t est aimée is des familles
sont allées individuellement dans les
commissariats parisiens faire des mains
courantes
il a fallu que la cnil en deux mois
d'investigations trouvent les faits
suffisamment graves pour rendre publique
procédure exceptionnelle son injonction
de mettre fin à des pratiques dans cinq
domaines qui met en cause
l'atteinte à la dignité des droits les
plus élémentaires de la vie privée un an
après les faits seulement le maire de
paris a déclenché d'abord une audit
externe
réponse très efficace évidemment chacun
connaît le procédé et d'autre part a
demandé de mettre fin à ces pratiques
il était temps pourtant généralement ce
ne sont pas les donneurs de leçons les
moralistes autour de lui qui sont avares
de recommandations qu'elle pointe
ce fichage massif ce fichage massif
ce fichage massif automatisé automatisé
sur un logiciel spécifique touche des
milliers de familles des familles les
plus fragiles de la capitale
ceux ci on veut nous faire croire
monsieur le ministre qu'il s'agit d'un
simple dérapage administratif alors que
340 gardien d'immeuble peuvent avoir des
informations et enrichir ce fichier sur
diverses informations qu'il s'agit d'un
simple dérapage administratif ce ne sont
pas eux qui ont commandé ce fichier se
sont pas eux qui l'ont payé ce ne sont
pas eux qui les utilisent depuis des
années
si la réponse du maire n'est pas
approprié il vous appartient monsieur le
ministre
au nom du respect des libertés
individuelles de faire en sorte que
l'état protège les citoyens et cette
protection doit s'exercer le plus tôt
possible
il ne suffit pas de masquer cette
affaire et je vous demande d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire pour que l'on
détermine le nombre des victimes de ces
procédures merci madame valérie pécresse
ministre du budget des comptes publics
et de la réforme de l'état
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur philippe dominati je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence de michel mercier
qui est actuellement en déplacement à
cayenne monsieur le sénateur jeudi
dernier la cnil a rendu publique une
mise en demeure mise en demeure qu'elle
a adressée à l'office public de
l'habitat de paris cette mise en demeure
constitue la première phase d'une
procédure pouvant mener en cas de
méconnaissance persistante des
dispositions de la loi informatique et
libertés du 6 janvier 1978
au prononcé d'une sanction
administrative par la formation
restreinte de la commission le
gouvernement ne saurait bien entendu
prendre position dans une procédure qui
est diligentée par une autorité
administrative indépendante sur la base
un dossier auquel il n'a pas accès des
éléments rendus publics par la cnil il
ressort néanmoins que l'office public de
l'habitat de paris aurait pu en
violation des dispositions de la loi
informatique et liberté et sans en
demander l'autorisation à la cnil
collecter des données sur la vie privée
des personnes qui ne
sont pas nécessaires à la gestion
locative notamment des données médicales
et des jugements de valeur sur les
locataires
la commission a donc donné deux mois à
l'office parisien pour mettre son
fichier en conformité avec la loi
indépendamment de la procédure
diligentée par la cnil je rappelle à la
haute assemblée que le code pénal punit
le fait de mettre ou de conserver en
mémoire informatisée des données à
caractère personnel qui sont relatives à
la santé d'une personne sans son
consentement et en dehors
les cas prévus par la loi merci monsieur
françois marque pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre et concerne les
annonces très inquiétante de l'état en
matière de dotations financières aux
collectivités des annonces
ministérielles récentes ont fait état
d'une réduction programmée de 6
milliards voire de 10 milliards d'euros
demain se tiendra d'ailleurs à l'elysée
la conférence des déficits publics et le
chef de l'état vient par avance de
réitérer ces mises en cause des
collectivités et de leurs élus en
imaginant de soumettre leurs dotations à
une modulation au mérite qui serait ce
juge impartial de la bonne ou de la
mauvaise gestion des communes des
départements ou des régions mystère
total
choqué le président du cfl gilles carez
on vient d'ailleurs à réclamer qu'on
arrête je cite de jouer au père
fouettard avec les collectivités
l'az et de la décentralisation a été une
excellente chose pour la qualité des
services publics dans notre pays
mais on le sait l'état c'est parfois
trop facilement décharger sur les
collectivités des compétences
transférées n'ont pas été correctement
compensés comme l'action sociale dans
les départements non content de
solliciter 116 les territoires pour des
compétences de niveau national at-elle
le tgv
ou le très haut débit le gouvernement a
mis en oeuvre une réforme fiscale qui
prive aujourd'hui les collectivités de
toute marge de manoeuvre
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui est
donc très simple
depuis trente ans les élus locaux se
sont dépensés sans compter pour donner
corps à la décentralisation et offrir un
service public de grande qualité
et ceci dans le cas du gestion
extraordinairement vertueuse or si les
collectivités se voit demain retirer
plusieurs milliards de leurs moyens
financiers
vous devez nous dire monsieur premier
ministre dans quel domaine vous demandez
à réduire ses services publics locaux
s'agite et de la sécurité on sait que
pour pallier la suppression par l'état
de 10000 postes de policiers les
communes ont de leur côté créer dix
mille postes de policiers municipaux
faudra-t-il réduire cet effort s'agit-il
de l'enfance on sait aujourd'hui la
baisse considérable du nombre
d'enseignants on sait que la
scolarisation des 2 à 3 ans s'étiole et
on sait que les communes ont dû dès lors
mettre en place des crèches des jardins
d'éveil de multiples actions pour les
familles allez vous contraindre les
communes à réduire leurs efforts pour la
petite enfance et la jeunesse
ou s'agit-il enfin de réduire les aides
aux personnes âgées handicapées assuré
dans les départements voulez vous couper
les aides pour l'apa pour l'insertion
pour la dépendance
vous devez nous dire monsieur le premier
ministre au delà de ces annonces de
réduction considérable de moyens sur
quels services publics de proximité
vous allez demander à faire porter
l'effort est la sécurité est la petite
enfance et la jeunesse s les personnes
âgées les handicapés vous devez répondre
oui monsieur
philippe richert ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur françois
marque nous interroger vous interroger
le gouvernement sur le contexte du
sommet local est en réalité ce sommet
local répond tout simplement à
l'engagement du président de la
république qu'il avait pris le 11
janvier dernier à l'occasion de tv aux
parlementaires où il indiquait qu'il
avait l'intention de réunir les
présidents des associations d'élus et
des deux assemblées pour examiner
ensemble les voies et les moyens
permettant de mieux associer les
collectivités locales à l'indispensable
effort de réduction du déficit public
en effet il n'est pas possible d'exclure
des collectivités territoriales du champ
de maîtrise des dépenses publiques je
vais le redire ici je les ai déjà fait j
indique à nouveau les chiffres si vous
prenez tout simplement le budget de
l'état si vous enlevez la parquet
reversés aux collectivités
ces 280 milliards d'euros si vous prenez
le total des dépenses des collectivités
ces 220 à 230 milliards d'euros au total
donc 500 millions 500 milliards d'euros
de dépenses des collectivités état plus
collectivités locales bien il n'est pas
possible d'imaginer que demain nous
puissions clairement aller et progresser
dans la maîtrise de la dépense publique
si nous n'associons pas à la fois l'état
et en même temps les collectivités
c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit exactement
la cour des comptes qui a insisté dans
ce rapport public sur la nécessité de
ralentir la dépense locale et de gelée
ou de réduire les dotations de l'état
au delà de 2012 je ne fais que citer ce
que dit la cour des comptes
le diagnostic au delà des dépenses
concernées vous le savez bien aussi la
question des personnels entre 98 et 2009
les effectifs de l'état hors transferts
de compétences et transferts de
personnel diminuent de 50000 de 59 mille
agents en même temps hors transferts les
collectivités locales recruter plus de
400 mille salariés
voilà la voilà la réalité ces chiffres
ces chiffres sont correspondent à la
réalité et le souffre d'aucune
contestation
mais permettez moi de dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
au delà de ce débat l'heure n'est pas à
la mise en cause
où est la confrontation stérile la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques doit
être un objectif partagé par tous et
chaque contribution
peut-être la bienvenue c'est dans cet
esprit que le gouvernement autour du
président de la république aborde la
conférence sur les finances locales
les voix de parvenir à une meilleure
maîtrise de la dépense locale reste
ouverte et faire l'objet d'un véritable
dialogue
voilà l'esprit dans lequel la rencontre
de demain est prévue
merci monsieur louis pinton pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé des transports et porte
sur la redéfinition des priorités entre
les liaisons ferroviaires à grande
vitesse au sein du schéma national des
infrastructures de transport
les choix stratégiques pour la desserte
combiné des quatre régions auvergne
bourgogne centre et limousin par la
grande vitesse ferroviaire doivent
satisfaire à trois critères le
doublement urgent de la ligne lgv
paris-lyon un aménagement équilibré du
territoire une rentabilité confirment et
de l'exploitation
une seule et unique solution technique
satisfait à l'ensemble de ces critères
c'est le tracé ouest de la ligne lgv
paris clairement lyon raccordé à la
ligne classique paris toulouse via
châteauroux il a recueilli l'avis
unanime des collectivités concernées
je vous réitère la demande constante des
élus assorti d'une requête qui n'est que
son prolongement logique
l'inscription en priorité au sein du
snit de ce projet qui donne satisfaction
à tous et particulièrement à lima
dans son cahier d'acteur la sncf s'est
rallié à ce type de position en
préconisant je cite un raccordement de
poc à la classique paris châteauroux
limoges entre bourges et issoudun et la
création de raccordement vers
châteauroux pour prolonger les dessertes
tgv peuple jusqu'à limoges et brive
fermez les guillemets rff a publiquement
admis la nécessité d'étendre le
périmètre du projet paris lyon afin
d'intégrer le niveau de service sur
paris limoges est suggéré l'éventualité
d'une révision de l'ordre des priorités
au sein du snit
enfin la très représentatif fédération
nationale des usagers d'infrastructures
de transport vient de ranger le poc dans
ses cinq grands projets prioritaires et
al'inverse a placé le barreau limoges
poitiers en tête de ce qu'elle estime
devoir être différée soulignant en
particulier je cite que sa réalisation
assécherait la ligne classique polt
fermez les guillemets monsieur le
ministre quelles mesures comptez vous
prendre pour d'amener pour donner
satisfaction aux collectivités
territoriales